[Música]
segundo bloque economía en directo
américa ya está conmigo nuevamente en el
estudio daniela blandón danny bienvenida
otra vez le pregunto cuáles son las
propuestas de los económicas por
supuesto los candidatos a la presidencia
de chile estos últimos dos que quedaron
de la primera vuelta ayer hola a raúl de
nuevo pues sabemos que dos posturas
absolutamente
extrema se van a enfrentar este próximo
19 de diciembre otra vez en las urnas
por un lado gabriel boric es un ex líder
estudiantil de izquierda ecologista y
feminista que busca implantar una
especie de estado del bienestar parecido
al de europa su programa abarca una
fuerte expansión fiscal quiere eliminar
la polémica administración privada de
pensiones y acabar con el modelo
económico neoliberal que por años ha
regido en el país neuro neoliberal
quiere decir que es una vida privatizada
propone también un impuesto a los super
ricos que ya ha sido discutido sin éxito
en el congreso y otro más a las
actividades no amigables con el medio
ambiente entre otras más regalías
mineras
pues josé antonio kast por su parte ha
rechazado que lo consideren de extrema
derecha sin embargo dice que augusto
pinochet habría votado por él y es el
seguidor del expresidente de eeuu donald
trump y también del jefe de estado de
brasil jair bolsonaro ahora veamos sus
propuestas a construir una franja en el
norte del país para frenar la migración
ilegal es una de ellas está también de
acuerdo con las afp y busca continuar un
modelo económico de libre mercado
también dice que aboga por un estado más
eficiente con el gasto y cree que bajar
impuestos corporativos y reducir el
papel del estado en la economía van a
ayudar a promover inversiones en el país
cambiamos ahora de información porque el
programa mundial de alimentos comenzó a
distribuir ayudas esto en afganistán si
hay muchas de las familias que tenían
buenos ingresos en el mes pero en este
momento se están viendo pues bastante
afectadas por la situación económica y
no tienen que llevar a sus mesas por eso
naciones unidas está atribuyendo la
situación a la llegada al poder de los
talibanes que implicó dejar de recibir
de la comunidad internacional y que se
ha visto agravada por los efectos de la
pandemia y la extrema sequía la onu
entonces decidió incrementar su programa
de ayudas el fin de semana a cientos de
ciudadanos comenzaron a recibir dinero
en efectivo
'esperamos mil familias y pagaremos a
cada una siete mil afganos durante dos
meses
esta ayuda será durante cuatro meses en
el distrito 14 y lo haremos en dos
plazos como primero distribuimos
alimentos y ahora estamos distribuyendo
dinero en efectivo bueno la situación es
tan difícil que el año pasado el
programa mundial de alimentos distribuyó
ayudas a más de 9 millones de personas y
este año la cifra ya mba en 14 millones
y todavía no se ha acabado el año bueno
danny vamos a hablar de china porque
promete el gobierno de ese país ayuda a
las pequeñas empresas bueno hay varias
afectaciones en las microempresas en
china y también en el resto del mundo
que son los altos precios de las
materias primas también la escasez de
energía y los nuevos brotes de kobe 19
pues el gabinete chino dijo este lunes
que intensificaría el apoyo a estas
microempresas pero sólo a aquellos que
tengan potencial de mercado a largo
plazo y también que sean preferiblemente
relacionados con la tecnología habrá
fondos de ayuda y exenciones fiscales
entre otros pero el énfasis principal
según han dicho las autoridades será la
lucha contra el acaparamiento y la
especulación con las materias primas que
finalmente esto es lo que hace que suban
los precios en estas épocas e
indicadores económicos le voy mejor con
las cifras
claro que sí millones de dólares 6 mil
millones de dólares no es una cifra
corta el fondo monetario internacional
dijo que llegó a un acuerdo con pakistán
para ayudarle a reactivar un programa de
financiación por este monto que lleva
estancado desde principios de este año
en medio de los crecientes desafíos
económicos en este país dani gracia
entonces por esta información económica
por el día de hoy nos vemos mañana con
más economía ahora nos vamos directo
hasta la silla de parís